bonsoir michael lambert merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on en
a discuté avec thomas bonnet sur place
un passé ces élections locales notamment
en virginie où les républicains ont
repris la main joe biden est dans une
position extrêmement délicate c'est un
revers vraiment important il ya vraiment
une désillusion by donne
oui effectivement un merci de
m'accueillir pour en parler il y a une
forme de désillusion puisque il y avait
beaucoup d'attentes vis-à-vis de
l'élection d'un candidat démocrate pour
essayer de d'éviter cette fracture
sociale peut être aller dans le sens
d'une protection environnementale plus
importante on s'attendait en fait à
beaucoup de choses et que ce soit sur un
plan interne comme sur un plan externe
on constate des défaillances avec
notamment l'inflation du dollar
américain qui pose problème pour de
nombreux foyers la hausse des prix
énergétiques a une fracture sociale
comme j'ai dit qui s'accentue mais
également sur un plan international
trade un manque de satisfaction
notamment avec le retrait dramatique des
troupes d'afghanistan manque
d'initiatives environnementales ou
encore une fois des choix inquiétant on
pense notamment au fait d'équiper des
sous marins à propulsion nucléaire en
australie et ce au détriment d'un pays
alliés comme la france donc tous ces
éléments laissent perplexes et ça amène
le public américain ne pas savoir
vraiment si si cette transition est
bonne et si un site gouvernance
démocrate va permettre vraiment au pays
d'aller de l'avant et malheureusement on
pensait que donald trump à les bloquer
absolument tout et maintenant on se rend
compte que des démocrates comme joe
biden ne font pas avancer pour autant
thomas cet échec a dont on vient de
parler il faut dire que c'est un test
important ce soir on l'a précisé mais à
un an des élections de mi-mandat tout
aussi importante
oui du coup il ya de l'inquiétude du
côté du parti démocrate qui ont voix et
déjà en proie à des guerres intestines
au sein du parti démocrate ce serait
évidemment dramatique pour joe biden que
de perdre la majorité au congrès et puis
il faut aussi suivre avec attention je
vous en parlais déjà un petit peu de la
cote de popularité de joe biden 53 %
d'approbation au mois d'avril 42
aujourd'hui selon donc ce sondage nbc
qui montre aussi que 71% des américains
interrogés estiment que le pays est sur
la mauvaise voie évidemment il ya des
ces chiffres sont directement liés donc
à l'inaction de joe biden qui est
bloquée au congrès mais aussi par un
certain nombre de décisions votre invité
en a parlé on peut par exemple évoqué
l'euro très chaotique des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan
et puis surtout le parti démocrate va
devoir adopter peut-être une nouvelle
stratégie puisque jusqu alors ils
stratégie consistait à diaboliser les
électeurs de donald trump et on voit
qu'en virginie cela n'a pas fonctionné
ça a même pu être contre-productif il
reste donc à 1 en démocrate pour tenter
de mettre sur pied une nouvelle
stratégie électorale c'est vrai que
michael lambert on a vu que même si les
républicains avaient pris ses distances
avec donald trump le démocrate payer aux
glyphes a beaucoup basé sa campagne sur
cette diabolisation de donald trump est
manifestement eh bien ça ne fait plus ou
pas recette
effectivement je dirais même que c'est
assez problématique puisqu'elle a été
élue dans la tendance anti donald trump
donc l'idée c'était d'avoir absolument
tout sauf donald trump est ce qui n'a
fait qu'accentuer la fracture au niveau
des états unis et le programme lui-même
n'était pas très élaboré malheureusement
dans un contexte d'urgence notamment
d'urgence climatique on voit tout
paradoxe d'ailleurs d'un côté il faut
avoir des prix énergétiques qu'ils
soient plus bas mais d'un autre côté il
faut éviter le réchauffement climatique
donc c'est une transition qui
nécessitait d'avoir peut-être plus
d'investissement dans des secteurs clés
qui plus est c'est vrai qu'il faut le
rappeler c'est un président qui rca j'ai
donc qui n'a peut-être même pas les
mêmes attentes vis-à-vis d'un public
américain petit peu plus jeunes c'est un
élément qu'on n'ose pas vraiment
mentionné mais qui et qui à prendre en
considération être président c'est
également avoir beaucoup d'énergie et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement monsieur byden à un
certain âge
d'un élément qu'on devrait mentionner
quand même un peu plus souvent selon moi
thomas en tout cas cette victoire vient
du mit à ce qu'elle pourrait servir
certains aimeraient bien les militants
de donald trump de deux suites
politiques aux républicains et à
l'ancien président
évidemment pour les républicains quand
vient le moment d'analyser cette
victoire en virginie peut-être certains
pourront se dire qu'il s'agit là d'un
modèle de positionnement stratégique
pour les futurs candidats républicains
notamment lors des mythes terme vidal
notamment sur le positionnement
vis-à-vis de donald trump on sait que
l'ancien président a encore une base
électorale très fidèle très solide et
très large mais il peut aussi paraître
clivant pour les électeurs les plus
modérés et finalement le candidat
républicain en virginie a réussi
justement à jouer les équilibristes en
eux répudiant pas publiquement donald
trump mais en gardant toutefois une
certaine forme de distance avec l'ancien
locataire de la maison blanche non
stratégiques a donc porté ses fruits en
virginie on verra si elle est applicable
ailleurs aux états unis il faut aussi
noter que la stratégie adoptée par le
candidat républicain en virginie a été
celle de se présenter comme le candidat
des parents il a beaucoup été question
des programmes scolaires américains du
contenu des programmes scolaires
également du fait que des écoles avaient
été fermées en temps de co vide c'est un
sujet qui est beaucoup revenus pendant
la campagne et qui pourrait à nouveau
ressurgir lors des élections de mi
mandat mais quelle lambert vous vous y
croyez pas vraiment à ce retour de
donald trump vous avez mentionné son âge
tout à l'heure mais enfin lui aimerait
bien et ses militants ou s'il ya
alors un retour de donald trump
peut-être pas c'est vrai que c'est une
personnalité qui qui va amener à plus de
clivage peut-être un retour des
démocrates c'est une possibilité
notamment en raison des taxes qui sont
très élevés et on constate des
défaillances par exemple vous le
constater au niveau des milliardaires
qui s'expatrient de californie pour
aller au texas ce qui semble assez
paradoxale d'un côté d'avoir le texas
qui devient la nouvelle californie
puisqu'il ya une politique démocrate qui
justement des eaux presse en californie
donc à partir de là peut-être un retour
des républicains sur le long terme de
donald trump
chances sont quand même assez minces
mais encore une fois il s'est montré
apte à détruire tout type de
statistiques devant lui donc c'est vrai
afat affaire à suivre on en est encore
très loin
merci beaucoup en tout cas michael
lambert thomas bonnin en direct de
washington d'avoir été avec nous